Are you ready
are you
Welcome back everyone this will be my full obi-wan
kenobi episode 5 star wars video there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs and obviously we only
have one episode left so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we've got the star wars rogue one prequel
series andor episodes coming really soon after
this too i'll be doing videos for that as well
along with all the other big marvel and
star wars series this year and next year too
mandalorian season 3 right around the corner we're
also doing a disney plus giveaway for memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just leave your favorite moment from the episode
on the video everyone hoping that they saved all
the really good stuff for the last two episodes
careful for spoilers for the episode if you
haven't seen it yet we'll be talking about
everything we'll just start at the beginning and
work our way through shot by shot talking about
wtf moments easter eggs as we go along starting
with the opening scene the episode starts with a
really cool darth vader flashback to when he was
still anakin skywalker practicing his lightsaber
skills with obi-wan kenobi during the prequels
now because of the way his hair is styled with the
padawan braid that means that this is still closer
to the events of attack of the clones he didn't
get the longer different haircut until they got
to the events of revenge of the sith even during
the clone wars when he lost the padawan braid and
ahsoka became his padawan his hair changed again
so this is before ahsoka became his padawan during
the episode there are several flashbacks like this
to this same instance their fight and even though
it is really cool to see they want to use it to
comment on obi-wan kenobi's plan to use darth
vader's weakness against him his desire to win
to dominate every win they also use a lot of these
moments in their dialogue together to kind of
foreshadow his eventual turn too like this super
aggressive nature that he has where he kind of
begrudgingly accepts obi-wan's tutelage thinking
that he's one but being tricked by obi-wan
ultimately they also want to foreshadow what their
rematch is going to be like during the finale
because obviously they have to end the series with
darth vader not going after obi-wan kenobi again
not going back to tattooing right after the events
of the finale because if he thought that only when
kenobi was still alive hiding out on tatooine
protecting luke he would have gone right back
there they revealed darth vader named reva grand
inquisitor but it's all a misdirect because of the
big twist at the end of the episode the way that
he waves past all her pleasantries saying that
he doesn't care about any of that that's also true
he doesn't care about that stuff to begin with but
also this is meant to foreshadow him knowing about
everything that she was doing this whole time
you didn't think that i sensed what was going
on the whole time young padawan the funny thing
about darth vader and the inquisitors is that
he uses all of them as his pawns as his tools
in his true goals so even though they use it as a
big wtf reveal in this episode really he doesn't
care about any of them obi-wan is correct when he
says darth vader only cares about me remember even
though leia is with him he doesn't know anything
about leia being his daughter yet which is why
he never mentions her during the episode they
bring back hodges character reminding you that
he's still a scoundrel with a heart of gold han
solo style like good business opportunities here
but this is also the only place for me to go so
i'm gonna throw my lot in with you completely
they might wind up justifying his inclusion in the
finale by saying that he does something to help
obi-wan kenobi make darth vader think that he's
dead so that he's going to be safe on tatooine
some of this is a little bit of plot armor and
just kind of stalling for time like obviously they
want to have the scene with darth vader arriving
on the planet so that's what the whole lola plot
is during the episode trying to keep them from
leaving the planet when they say they only have a
few hours left that's also meant to be a reference
to the end of the series like we'll wrap this up
in the next two hours and yes rokin is played by
o'shea jackson ice cube's real life son he looks
just like him he's never done star wars before
so he is meant to be a brand new character in
the universe as they pan around the room they
have a couple of r2 units this one is slightly
modified i'm not sure what kind of droid this
is specifically but it's based on an r2 droid
there's a regular r2 droid later in the episode
love all the shots of darth vader brooding
meditating during their hyperspace journey
he spends most of his time in states like
this just fixated on his anger specific things
whatever his goal is during any particular moment
mostly he's thinking back on padme dying the
events of the past or preparing for specific
fighter battle in this case he's headed to capture
obi-wan kenobi again and torture him for a long
long time so he hopes that's why he keeps flashing
back to their fight scene it's not meant to be
obi-wan kenobi's flashbacks it's meant to be darth
vader's flashbacks but remember because he doesn't
know about luke and leia he's only obsessed with
obi-wan kenobi he's been obsessed with him for the
past 10 years that's why during several parts of
the episode he makes references to the fact that
he doesn't really care about what else is going
on here with the path in this resistance here with
them trying to save the force sensitives because
he literally only cares about obi-wan kenobi the
actual planet jabim is actually a huge deep
cut from the clone wars in the tie-in material
obi-wan kenobi had some missions there during
the clone wars there's a ton of arabesh writing
on the walls of the cave here if you speak the
language or you think you've decoded some of these
writings here write them below in the comments
i believe it's meant to be the same ideas the
jedi names written on the walls of that other
hidden room in previous episodes most of these
writings are the names of other jedi characters
from the canon and from legends material that
they brought back into the canon like we saw
karan horn's father's name in the other room
one of these would also probably have been written
by quinlan voss remember tala said that pretty
much everybody that passed through that room that
rode on those walls also passed through the halls
of jabim here in this hangar bay but the symbol
here in the center is the symbol of the jedi
order and it confirms the phrase right below it
reads the light will fade but is never forgotten
and that's meant to be a reference to a couple
different things it's a reference to order 66
and the emperor killing off the jedi order meaning
that even though the inquisitors the emperor have
been going after them and they're killing lots
of them they're not going to completely kill
the light side of the force they're not going to
completely kill the jedi order it will eventually
survive in some way and that's a reference to luke
skywalker's eventual jedi academy also with grogu
eventually being the future of the jedi order even
though it sounds like he's going to take things
in a slightly different direction than what luke
skywalker was doing so the phrase is also meant to
be a reference to luke skywalker the original
trilogy to leia also to darth vader anakin
skywalker because eventually even though the light
fades in him like he turns to the dark side of the
force becomes a sith eventually he redeems himself
and tries to kill the emperor so even though the
light side in him faded briefly it was never fully
forgotten you see a whole bunch of lightsabers
from former jedi that have died in this box let
me know if you think who these lightsabers belong
to specifically these are also traditional jedi
robes then they have this whole subplot with reva
hijacking lola and forcing her to sabotage the
facility i think to create something for leia to
do during the episode because otherwise she's just
kind of sitting there waiting for them to escape
the whole subplot with her helping them escape
is also just meant to foreshadow what she's like
during the original trilogy love the way they set
up some of these flashbacks though when obi-wan
kenobi's talking about how darth vader isn't
gonna wait for prolonged siege he doesn't have
the patience for that then they literally show
that happening during their flashback fight scene
and it's meant to be the same fight just different
parts of the fight if you watch any of the clone
wars episodes this is a bit of a reference to
anakin skywalker during those because during
those episodes he will frequently ignore obi-wan
kenobi's orders in the jedi council's orders to
just do whatever he wants rush into any kind of
problem that he thinks he's going to solve it's
like a core part of his character that he doesn't
like waiting also him fighting obi-wan on the
best path for a jedi during a battle killing
your opponents versus saving lies is meant to
foreshadow what he's going to do during revenge of
the sith killing count dooku and then turning to
the dark side of the force during a lot of these
darth vader and these anakin skywalker flashback
scenes you also hear a lot of imperial themed
music and imperial march themed music from the
original trilogy obi-wan kenobi taking charge here
to telling everybody what to do how they're going
to survive is more of him finally accepting the
call to action acting more like the general kenobi
from the clone wars the general kenobi that leia
was talking about when she was asking for his
help during the original trilogy as opposed to
the more broken version of the character that
we met at the beginning of the series where he's
at his lowest point emotionally they roll in with
several squads of stormtroopers purge troopers
from jedi fallen order and they're using the
sith inquisitor's scythe ship they're just calling
it the scythe ship and all the toys the transport
ships might look familiar because they also use
those during the mandalorian season too when they
went to capture grogu later in the timeline the
whole thing with bail organa's message just felt
kind of like a plot contrivance meant to help set
up the end of the episode with reva in the finale
trying to use luke skywalker against darth vader
again because during the message bail organa
specifically mentions tatooine owen lars name
which reva would have remembered and this mystery
child like he doesn't say the name luke skywalker
but reba will know that the child is connected
to obi-wan kenobi someone who's really important
in another opportunity she could potentially use
against darth vader to try and kill him again
you do notice during the scene though when he's
watching the message he plays with his beard
again the same way that alec guinness did during
the original trilogy just kind of mimicking his
mannerisms just trying to make his performance
line up with alec guinness as possible when tala
mentions she participated in an imperial raid
on guerrell that planet was actually featured
during a bunch of different star wars tv series
during star wars rebels the clone wars during
the original trilogy time material han solo had
some missions there during the star wars forces
of destiny animated series and the classic star
wars droids animated series the way that tala
talks about it she was there with the empire
after the events of revenge of the sith when they
were hunting other jedi when she talks about the
force sensitive families that she went after that
they captured it's basically her referencing what
the inquisitors and darth vader did capturing them
torturing them then putting them in these stasis
pods and using their bodies for weird jedi cloning
experiments which are actually still playing out
in the present day of the timeline during the
mandalorian series with grogu darth vader and the
emperor also kept these jedi bodies and stasis as
trophies but they really also wanted to use them
for experiments a lot of you probably suspected
what was really going on with the reva character
that there was some big twist with her trying
to go after darth vader or turning good they
confirmed that when obi wan kenobi is speaking
to her through the blast door possibly setting up
her surviving in the finale they explain how she
knew that darth vader was really anakin skywalker
obie when kenobi even calls this out like they
would have kept that secret darth vader would
have probably killed off anybody who had talked
about that they confirm our suspicions she was
that particular padawan during the night of order
66 and she says she only survived by pretending to
be dead but then they also tie this in with the
reveal that darth vader knew the whole time that
she was alive that she was that padawan and just
used her because he thought that she was useful
not because he was showing mercy on her remember
even though they're on the same side darth vader
does not care about any of the other imperials he
doesn't care about the inquisitors so if a bunch
of them wind up dying he doesn't care about that
he'll just replace them eventually love the order
66 flashback scene 2 where they finally show you
anakin skywalker killing younglings it's actually
way more graphic than i expected it's a brand new
scene too because obviously it's a slightly older
looking hayden christensen you have to picture
grogo experiencing all this in just a slightly
different part of the jedi temple he would have
been going through all this just like reva went
through it because he was doing the exact same
thing during this period but they explained
during his flashback when luke skywalker was
helping him remember the trauma is that he was
saved by a couple of the other jedi that used
themselves as human shields against the other
clone troopers that had come for them so while
anakin skywalker is busy killing these younglings
here you have to picture grogu just nearby getting
ready to escape i think we can expect something
similar to this when we get to the ahsoka episodes
which are going to happen later in the timeline
there'll be some kind of flashbacks and we'll see
anakin skywalker in the flesh hayden christensen
doing scenes with a younger looking version of
ahsoka but obviously the big wtf reveal here is
that she's secretly been plotting to kill darth
vader in revenge for order 66 for killing her
friends the other jedi the padawans at the temple
this whole time the past 10 years but if there
was a little bit confusion about what's going on
inside her head she's still gone to the dark side
it's not like she's secretly been a light-side
jedi playing a double agent this whole time she
still legit tried to torture leia a little 10 year
old girl she admits to torturing and killing many
of those other force-sensitive former jedi that
we saw in the amber in that room so she turned
to the dark side and it was only her ambition
to kill darth vader that kept her going all the
flashbacks of obi-wan kenobi using that against
darth vader using his desire to win against him
is meant to be a mirror for reva storyline too
she was so fixated on killing darth vader that
she was blinded to what was actually going on oh
he knew the whole time but that explains why she
wanted to become grand inquisitor to be by his
side so to speak so she could literally be in
close proximity to him to give her an opportunity
to actually kill him even though he's so powerful
she would have never been able to do it even if
he didn't see it coming which he did so just to
clarify anakin skywalker wasn't fooled by her
when she was a padawan pretending to be dead he
knew that she was still alive and just played her
these whole 10 years the scene of her using the
lightsaber to open the blast door is meant to be a
reference to obi-wan kenobi and qui-gon jinn doing
the same thing in phantom menace also kind of
reminding you qui-gon jin oh yeah we're probably
gonna hear his force ghost at some point during
the finale because they've been saying his name
so many times during the series i've already done
a video all about qui-gon jim potentially cameoing
on the series and why that would happen what's
going on with his character and how his force
spirit is able to exist now why it's a little bit
different from being a force ghost so i'll post
a link for that down in the description below
they have a huge battle scene here love the way
that they are actually pretty accurate with the
way they portray the stormtrooper's skill level
they have several squads but they barely managed
to hit any of these people barely managed to kill
any of these people either it seems like one of
the only people that actually winds up dying is
tala in that ned droid and that's because they
purposefully stand in the line of fire to try and
sacrifice themselves allowing the others to escape
is not because the stormtroopers got a one-up on
them during this final part of the episode too
including the darth vader scenes when he lands
on planet most of this music is meant to be new
but inspired by john williams original trilogy
classic music tala whips out a thermal detonator
and says the classic phrase may the force be with
you she's not meant to be force sensitive herself
she was just meant to be an ally for the jedi
but the reason that darth vader has their forces
stand down is because he can sense what's happened
through the force he can sense obi-wan's intention
to surrender in order to protect the others that's
why they juxtaposed this with the flashback about
them fighting each other and all of obi-wan's
lessons to him he's trying to use what he knew
about obi-wan kenobi what he knows about him
against him the same way that obi-wan is trying to
use everything that he knows about darth vader and
his character against him so just to be clear even
though reva agrees to work with obi-wan kenobi
he's really just using her to throw at darth
vader to stall for time and she's just using
the situation to her advantage to get what she
wants she's not working with obi-wan kenobi out
of the goodness of her heart and she doesn't care
about saving any of the other force sensitives
when he arrives on jabim and starts marching
through the hallways they start playing a little
bit of the classic imperial march theme song
love the huge reveal here too like they show how
powerful he actually is in the dark side of the
force he stops the ship mid-air from taking off
this is also meant to be a reference to a similar
scene of him destroying another imperial ship
during the original trilogy era after a new
hope after he learned that luke skywalker
was really his son there was a scene during the
comics where he actually saves luke's life from
other imperials without him knowing about it
but like he literally reaches out in the force
and destroys an imperial ship before it's able
to get him everybody will also probably remember
that really iconic shot of the force unleashed
of starkiller doing the same thing but with
a giant star destroyer like an entire star
destroyer that he brings down with the force
it's also meant to be a dark mirror for the scene
of yoda lifting luke skywalker's x-wing out of
the swamp in empire strikes back talking about the
power of the force showing you how powerful darth
vader really is even though technically because
there's still light side in him that he can't
completely get rid of he's not as powerful as he
could potentially be and if you don't remember
from the prequel movies or you don't remember the
clone wars anakin skywalker was meant to be way
way more powerful with a lightsaber than obi-wan
kenobi that's why he's able to disarm him so
quickly the reason why obi-wan kenobi is able to
ultimately defeat him during that flashback battle
is because obi-wan kenobi is more of a work
smarter not harder kind of person in anakin
skywalker is that work harder person like just
dominate the fight try to win as quick as possible
so they just want to show you the obi-wan kenobi
is wiser than anakin skywalker darth vader also in
the flashbacks when he says he'll stay a padawan
a learner so to speak until he overcomes this
weakness of his character is meant to reference
their eventual original trilogy fight on the death
star in a new hope when darth vader says that he's
done that he's overcome that weakness saying he's
no longer the learner now he is the master then
i love the way this darth vader vs reva fight
plays out we all knew it was coming at a certain
point like yeah he probably saw this coming he's
way too powerful for her during their actual fight
she's got no chance like there's no way she's ever
gonna beat him so he's vastly more powerful just
kind of playing with her the way that he toyed
with obi-wan kenobi during their first rematch
in episode three that's why the fight is meant
to look a little bit like obi-wan kenobi's first
rematch with them like it's not so much an actual
lightsaber fight it's really just him kind of
stretching just practicing a little bit the
scene of him forced grabbing her lightsaber and
splitting the two halves wielding two a couple
times in the episode is meant to be a reference
to him using two lightsabers on count dooku during
revenge of the sith him running her through the
stomach is also meant to be a reference to her
trying to run the grand inquisitor through the
stomach the same way because literally right
after this he shows up to reveal their plan like
oh yeah we were playing you the whole time i've
been alive this whole time also confirming that
they are preserving the timeline because the grand
inquisitor doesn't actually die till the events
of star wars rebels way later in the timeline
i was kind of hoping when they brought him back
they would bring him back with a special sith
eyes that you see during star wars rebels all the
sith armor that they wear too isn't just for show
it's meant to help keep them alive too like darth
vader survived the fight on mustafar so of course
the grand inquisitor wearing all that sith armor
would also probably survive the same way that
darth vader did the scene of obi-wan given pause
while they're escaping on the ship is meant to be
a reference to the many different scenes in star
wars where different characters especially leia
for instance say i've got a bad feeling about
this just foreshadowing reva surviving like the
grand inquisitor survived using the knowledge of
luke skywalker in this communicator against darth
vader and the inquisitor to try and get back
at them and kill him again so just to be clear
she hasn't turned good or anything she's still
fully a dark jedi she's still using the events
to her advantage to just try and kill him but
early prediction something will happen during
the finale and she will wind up surviving they've
been talking about doing obi-wan kenobi season two
so theoretically if they did a season two she
would come back during that i think the big
thing here though is they want to preserve the
timeline so ultimately darth vader will not learn
about luke skywalker's existence something will
probably have to happen that will make him think
that obi-wan kenobi is dead so that he doesn't go
right back to tatooine and look for him again so
let me know in the comments how do you think
they're going to pay off this final rematch
scene where do you think it's going to happen and
how do you think they're going to prevent darth
vader from fully learning about luke skywalker
if it sounds like reva is going to try and use
knowledge of luke skywalker against darth vader
again if you spotted any other easter eggs in the
episode that i didn't talk about in the video just
write them below in the comments my full obi-wan
kenobi episode 6 finale video we'll post next
week just like normal my miss marvel episode 2
video will post tomorrow morning everyone click
here for my brand new loki season 2 first look
breakdown in kang easter eggs and click here for
my brand new thor love and thunder trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!